el 14 de diciembre de 2020 sandra
lindsay una enfermera de la ciudad de
nueva york fue la primera persona en
recibir una dosis de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 un año después lejos de haber
superado la crisis está se mantiene con
un número de contagios en aumento y que
ya supera los 50 millones ello llevó al
estado de nueva york a imponer nuevas
medidas
las personas que atienden en casa es una
situación pero cuando presionan a un
sistema de salud agotado y hablo por
cada persona que trabaja allí incluyendo
a los altos ejecutivos por casi dos años
cualquier cosa que podamos hacer para
ayudar a aliviar esa olla de presión es
una de mis prioridades
es formar genes parís en otros estados
los contagios y hospitalizaciones
mantienen el sistema de salud colapsado
y el número de pacientes por la
enfermedad empieza a generar tensiones
entre los trabajadores de la salud hoy
fue bastante difícil porque es mi
tercero esta semana lo siento en eeuu el
brote de ccoo y 19 ha causado la muerte
de 798 mil personas más que en ningún
otro país del mundo y con un promedio de
30.000 muertes diarias en el último mes